many Germans have been closely following
the proceedings against Christian Wulff
it's the first time a former German
President had been put on trial that's
the trials are farce am i under the
guild he was a government representative
and as such the matter should be pursued
man crotch like nonsense others
appropriate so much money dig on
supporters the whole trial is laughable
think what it's about almost get in yet
so I got a bit much to humiliate him
this way peshab is nuba team just thirty
percent of Germans polled believe it was
right to put christian wulff on trial
the majority some sixty-six percent feel
the proceedings against the former
president were unwarranted for most
germans a wolf is still persona non
grata
over half of those asked in a
representative survey say he shouldn't
hold a public office despite being
acquitted thus the impression remains
that he was a corrupt state premier and
later German President Jacob is missed
das flipped sign his image has been
damaged a bit everyone deserves a second
chance you can't be condemned forever